[تصفيق]
مظاهرات في عدد من المدن الافغانيه رفضا
لقرار حكومه طالبان اغلاق الجامعات امام
الطالبات
اما في العاصمه كابول ففي الخفاء وبعيدا
عن اعين الامن الافغاني خوفا من العقاب
نفذ الطالبات جامعيات اعتصاما داخل منزل
احدهم تعبيرا عن رفضهن لقرار الحكومه
منعهن من التعليم
صيحات لمطالبه الحكومه التي تتزعملها
طالبان بالتراجع عن القرار الذي وصف
بالكارثه على مستقبل البلاد
اليوم لان طالبان اغلقت المدارس قبل سنه
امام الفتيات والخطوات الثانيه ستكون
اغلاق الجامعات اردن ان نتظاهر في الشارع
لكنهم لم يسمحوا لنا لذلك احتججنا هنا في
هذا المكان المغلق
احدى الفتيات التي صدمها القرار انهت
سنتها الاولى في كليه الطب بجامعه خاصه في
كابول والان دمر مستقبلها كما تقول
لم تصدقه اذنين كان خبرا صادما لي ولجميع
زميلاتي انا لا افكر بمغادرتي البلاد لان
وضعيه الماليه لا يسمح لكن زميلات يفكرنا
بصوره جديه في اكمال دراستهم خارج البلاد
الحكومه الافغانيه لم تعلق على القرار ولم
تبرره لكنها فعلته سابقا ففي حكم طالبان
الاول بين 96 من القرن الماضي
و2001 تكرر مشهد منع الطالبات من
التعليميه اغلاق المدارس والجامعات لكن
عندما ننظر من ناحيه الشرعيه فان التعليم
العصريه ضروره للشعب الافغاني وعلى
الاماره ان تراجع قرارها وان تفتح ابواب
المدارس والجامعه امام الفتيات
قرار طالبان اغلاق الجامعات الحكوميه
والخاصه امام الطالبات قابل باستهجان
المجتمع الدولي فيما طالبت منظمه الامم
المتحده الحكومه الافغانيه بفتح ابواب
الجامعات والمدارسين امام الفتيات
محليا قد يدفع قرار الحكومه الافغانيه الى
هجره المزيد من الافغان بهدف تعليم بناتهم
ودوليا يتوقع مراقبون ان يزيد هذا القرار
الضغط على حركه طالبان ويحضر الاعتراف بها
او التعامل معها ناصر شديد الجزيره كابول